واجه رئيس الوزراء بوريس جونسون
انتقادات شديدة في مجلس العموم اليوم
خلال جلسة طارئة ، وهذه هي
المرة الأولى التي يتم فيها الجمع بين النواب منذ أن تم رفع
قيود الإغلاق
بالكامل ، لذا فقد كان مكتظًا
وكان الجو صاخبًا ونعم في بعض الأحيان
كان غاضبًا وعاطفيًا  النقاش
بالطبع السؤال السائد هو كيف حدث هذا
كيف سقطت كابول بهذه السرعة
وماذا يعني هذا لدور المملكة المتحدة في
أفغانستان والتضحيات التي
قدمتها في ذلك البلد أكثر من 450
جنديًا بريطانيًا فقدوا حياتهم
خلال الحرب الأفغانية  أه رئيس الوزراء
بوريس جونسون بالطبع دافع عن
سجله وقال إن الحكومة
مستعدة للتداعيات ،
استمع ،
أعتقد أنه سيكون من العدل أن نقول إن
الأحداث في أفغانستان قد اندلعت
وكان الانهيار أسرع وأعتقد
حتى طالبان  هم أنفسهم تنبأوا
بما هو غير صحيح أن يقولوا أن حكومة المملكة المتحدة
أه كانت غير مستعدة أو لم
تتوقع ذلك لأنه أه كان بالتأكيد
ع  فن تخطيطنا لتأليب
العملية اللوجيستية الصعبة للغاية
لانسحاب المواطنين البريطانيين قيد التحضير
أه منذ عدة أشهر ،
أحد الشواغل الرئيسية للحكومة البريطانية
الآن هو إجلاء
المواطنين البريطانيين ولكن أيضًا للموظفين الأفغان
الذين دعموا
الحكومة البريطانية والجيش البريطاني على
مدى العقدين الماضيين ،
لا يزال هناك الآلاف ينتظرون
للخروج إلى بر الأمان ، وتقول المملكة المتحدة إن
رئيس الوزراء بوريس جونسون يمثل أولوية مطلقة
كما أعلن عن
خطة لإعادة التوطين ستشهد استقرار ما يصل إلى
20 ألف أفغاني هنا.  المملكة المتحدة
على مدار السنوات العديدة
القادمة ولكن في السنة الأولى
تقول الحكومة إنها تريد
إعادة توطين حوالي 5000 أفغاني هنا في المملكة المتحدة ،
ستُعطى الأولوية بالطبع
للفئات الضعيفة من النساء والفتيات
من حيث الإستراتيجية المستقبلية
لأفغانستان  رئيس الوزراء بوريس جونسون
يركل العلبة على الطريق ،
وسيعقد اجتماع G7 الأسبوع المقبل إلى dis  لعنة
ذلك مع قادة العالم الآخرين
سام عبد العزيز CNN لندن